New Google Stitch update is insane.
Google just dropped something wild. Like
actually wild. They just upgraded one of
the most powerful AI design tools on the
planet. It can now build entire
dashboards, full apps, and pixel perfect
layouts automatically, right? From a
single prompt. And nobody is talking
about this yet. So let me break it down
for you right now. So here is what just
happened. Google has this tool called
Stitch. And if you have not heard of it
yet, you need to pay attention because
this thing is about to change how we
build stuff online forever. [snorts] Let
me explain what Stitch actually does
first because once you get this, the
update is going to blow your mind.
Stitch is an AI tool from Google. You
type in a prompt. Like you you literally
describe what you want and it builds you
a full user interface like a real one.
Not some ugly wireframe, not some sketch
on a napkin. A real clean professional
UI. The kind of thing that used to take
a designer and a developer weeks to
build. Stitch does it in minutes. But
wait, it gets crazier. You can also
upload a sketch, like a rough drawing on
a whiteboard or a screenshot of an app
you like. And Stitch turns that into a
real interface, too. It looks at your
sketch and says, "Okay, I got you." And
builds the whole thing out. And then,
and this is the part that gets me
excited. It gives you the actual code,
HTML, CSS, sometimes even JSX. You can
export it straight into your project and
start building right away. Or you can
export it to Figma if you want to keep
designing. This is not a toy. This is a
real tool. So the old way of building
stuff used to look like this. You have
an idea. You go find a designer. The
designer spends days in Figma. Then you
hand it to a developer. The developer
spends more days turning it into code.
And by the time you actually have
something to look at, weeks have gone
by. With Stitch, it goes like this. You
have an idea, you type a prompt, you get
a full UI and code. Done. That is it.
That is the whole workflow now. But here
is where the new update comes in. And
this is the part that changes
everything. Google just put Gemini 3.1
Pro inside of Stitch. And if you do not
know what that means, let me break it
down real simple. Gemini 3.1 Pro is one
of Google's most powerful AI models. It
is smarter. It understands more. It can
hold way more information in its head at
once. And now it is the brain behind
Stitch. Hey, if we have not met already,
I am the digital avatar of Julian
Goldie, CEO of SEO agency Goldie Agency.
Whilst he is helping clients get more
leads and customers, I am here to help
you get the latest AI updates. Julian
Goldie reads every comment. So, make
sure you comment below. Okay, so back to
why this update is such a big deal.
There are three main upgrades here and
each one is massive. Number one, deep
context. Before this update, AI design
tools were kind of forgetful. You could
give them a simple task and they would
do okay, but if you tried to give them a
full design system with brand guidelines
and component libraries and multiple
screens, they would get confused. They
would lose track. Now, with Gemini 3.1
Pro, Stitch can hold all of that in its
head at once. Your brand colors, your
component library, your spacing rules,
your typography, all of it, and it keeps
it consistent across every screen it
generates. That is huge. Number two,
complex architecture. This is the one
that really got me. Before this update,
AI design tools were pretty good at
simple stuff. Landing pages, login
screens, basic cards, but the moment you
asked for something complex like a SAS
dashboard with charts and tables and
sidebar navigation and drop-own menus,
it would fall apart. Not anymore. With
this update, Stitch can now generate
full SAS dashboards, analytics tools,
enterprise admin panels, multi-step
forms, dense data tables, the kind of
stuff that real businesses actually
need. The kind of stuff that used to
require a whole design team. Stitch can
now do it from a prompt. Number three,
pixel precision. This sounds small, but
it is actually massive. The spatial
reasoning got way better. That means
cleaner CSS, better alignment,
consistent spacing, correct component
hierarchy. Basically, the output
actually looks like something a
professional designer built, not
something an AI guessed. So, let me give
you an example of what this looks like
in practice. Say you type this prompt
into Stitch. Build a SAS analytics
dashboard with KPI cards across the top,
a bar chart showing monthly revenue, an
activity feed on the right side, and a
subscription panel at the bottom. Before
this update, you would get something
okay. Maybe the layout would be a little
off. Maybe the spacing would be weird.
Maybe the components would not quite
work together. Now, with Gemini 3.1 Pro,
you get a clean, structured,
professional dashboard. Everything lined
up, everything spaced correctly,
everything looking like it belongs
together, and you get the code to go
with it. Now, real quick, if you are
watching this and you're thinking,
"Okay, I need to start using AI tools
like this in my business," then you need
to check out the AI Profit Boardroom. It
is the best place to scale your
business, get more customers, and save
hundreds of hours with AI automation. If
you want to learn how to use tools like
Google Stitch to build and grow faster,
the link is in the description and
comments. Go check it out. Okay, so let
me talk about who this is actually for
because I think a lot of people are
sleeping on this. If you are a startup
founder and you need to build an MVP
fast, this is for you. You do not need
to hire a designer. You do not need to
wait weeks. You can go from idea to a
working UI in minutes. If you are an
indie developer and you are building
something on your own, this is for you.
You can generate your entire front end
without touching Figma. If you run an
agency and you need to show clients
prototypes fast, this is for you. You
can build a prototype in the time it
takes to have a meeting about building a
prototype. If you are on a product team
and you want to test different UI
concepts quickly, this is for you. You
can generate multiple variants and
compare them side by side. You can say
make it dark mode or add three feature
cards or convert it to mobile layout and
stitch creates new variants instead of
overwriting your original design. Now I
do want to be real with you because I am
not going to sit here and tell you this
is perfect. It is not. There are some
limitations you need to know about.
First is stitch is still experimental is
part of Google labs. That means you
should expect some bugs. Some things
will not work exactly right. That is
just the reality of where we are right
now. Right. Second, it is front end
only. It generates the UI, the HTML, the
CIS, but it does not build your back
end. It does not set up your database.
It does not handle authentication. You
still need a developer for that stuff.
This is the design and front end piece.
Third, your prompts matter a lot. If you
type in something vague like make a cool
dashboard, you are going to get
something vague back. But if you type in
something specific like create a SAS
analytics dashboard with KPI cards, a
bar chart, and an activity table, you're
going to get something way better. The
better your prompt, the better your
output. Now, let me put this in
perspective for a second. Think about
the tools competing in this space right
now. You've got UX Pilot, which works
inside Figma. You've got Framer AI for
website generation. You've got Lovable
for full app building. You've got Bolt
for prompt to web apps. But here is what
makes Stitch different. It connects
design to code instantly in one tool
from Google with one of the most
powerful AI models on the planet running
behind it. That is a combination nobody
else has right now. And look, I have
been in the online business space for
years. I built a sevenf figureure agency
from the ground up. I have a team of 50
people and I can tell you the gap
between having an idea and having a
working product has never been smaller
than it is right now. AI is not
replacing designers and developers, but
it is replacing the slow, painful
process between an idea and a prototype.
Tools like Stitch are pushing us closer
and closer to prompt to product
development, where you can go from a
thought in your head to a working
interface in minutes. And that changes
everything for people who want to build
fast and test fast. So, here's what I
want you to do. Go to
stitch.withgoogle.com.
Try it out. Type in a prompt. Upload a
sketch.
see what it can do and then come back
here and tell me what you think in the
comments. Julian reads every single one.
And if you want the full process, SOPs
and over a 100 AI use cases like this
one, join the AI profit boardroom. He's
the best place to learn how to use AI
tools like Google Stitch to automate
your workflow, build faster, and scale
your business. The link is in the
description and comments. And if you
want free access to our community, join
the AI success lab. You will get all the
video notes from there, plus access to
our community of 38,000 members who are
crushing it with AI. Link is in the
comments and description.